Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus so kurz vor Weihnachten
kurz vor Toresschluss ich gebe es zu ich
bin jetzt ich meine traut sich ja gar
nicht mal laut zu sagen aber ich bin ein
bisschen im Fußballfieber du auch ja ich
auch ich wusste
das hat sich leicht bei uns zu Hause
auch nicht aus ja meine Lebensgefährtin
ist ebenfalls im Fußballfieber glühende
Anhängerin von Argentinien ja nachdem
eben ihr vorhin Spanier weggebrochen
sind
und sie hat überhaupt nicht verstanden
warum die Spanier gegen Marokko verloren
und ich versuche ihr das immer zu
erklären du hast es verstanden Spiel
Jungs gegen Männer und da gewinnen die
Männer natürlich ja weil die Spanier
spielen natürlich den besten Fußball der
Welt meine ich ganz ernst und Ironie
frei das ist so ich finde wenn man unter
Fußball wenn man unter Fußball versteht
den Ball in den eigenen Reihen zu halten
das ballettartig aus Italien und so
weiter ja
aber der das Problem ist natürlich dass
diese
guckt sie dir an ja die sehen nicht mehr
aus wie Spanier in den 80er oder 90er
Jahren aussehen das sind alles so Bein
rasierte Jungs ja die mit ihrem Martin
Tee am Strand sonst sitzen die sind so
lieb viele lieb für diese Welt ja die
sind ganz ganz lieb und wenn man ganz
ganz lieb ist wird man nicht Fußball
Weltmeister und Marokko ist überhaupt
nicht ganz ganz lieb aber die sind alle
alle drei Kategorien härter und drei
Kategorien männlicher also
Fußball naja also dass du also die tun
weh wenn man gegen die sind einfach mit
allen Abwassern gewaschen dreimal
chemisch gereinigt und und die haben
tatsächlich diesen trockenen Herzblut
mehr ja die den Jungs fehlt und deswegen
wenn Jungs gegen Männer spielen genau
darf man sich nicht wundern dass die
Männer gewinnen
also über dein Männerbild müssen wir mal
reden finde ich Richard ja da machen wir
gerne mal eine Folge so
freut mich jetzt schon drauf großartig
groß da bin ich schon gespannt was du
sagst und im Jahresrückblick wenn die
Rückblick aufs Jahr machen sollten wir
mal sprechen über diese legendäre
Ohrfeige von Will Smith gegen Chris Rock
ah ja da fällt mir auch zum Thema
Männlichkeit auch was so ein ehrlich ich
ahne in welche Richtung das geht so
vorstellen wenn ich Fußball gucke
Fußball nicht nur unter dem dem
fußballerischen Gesichtspunkten es gibt
ja immer so viele andere interessante
Dinge die sind ja immer so Revue
passieren lassen frühere
Weltmeisterschaften na da habe ich von
aus Valderrama erzählt Pudel aus
Kolumbien ja genau ja und ich so mit dem
gleichen Blick gucke ich natürlich auch
auf die Spieler von heute ja und mir
viel zum Beispiel auf Modric ja Luka
Modric es gab doch Luka Modric es gab ja
früher im Sternen mal diese Rubrik bei
der Geburt getrennt also zwei Leute die
miteinander nichts zu tun haben sich
aber verblüffend ähnlich sehen das ist
so ein Hobby von mir also ein Klassiker
für mich der nie im Stern war sind
Reinhard Mey und einer langen hat Rainer
ja gut ja absolut das gleiche Gesicht ja
und ich glaube immer reiner Langhans ist
Reinhard Mey mit Brücke ja vermutlich
das nur mal angucken und müsste sich so
eine graue Brücke auf Reinhard Meisdorf
ist gut bist du ein Beispiel und ich
finde Luca Modric ja ist auch bei der
Geburt getrennt worden und zwar von
Beatrix von Storch
ist nicht dein Ernst die sind sich total
in herrlich also du guckst Fußball so
obwohl man das ja eigentlich nicht darf
ne ja so darüber wollte ich heute mal
mit dir reden ja über das reden was man
darf und was man nicht darf und vor
allen Dingen wir sollten darüber reden
was die anderen dürfen und nicht dürfen
ja denn es ist ja ein großer Unterschied
ob man für sich selbst festlegt was man
darf und was man nicht darf so oder ob
man seinen Maßstab auf andere überträgt
und sagt das was ich für falsch halte
müssen andere auch für falsch
entscheiden das ist genau der Punkt und
weißt du was ganz kurz wenn ich einmal
kurz einhaken darf ich jetzt weil es so
gut passt ich hatte ja dieses Thema in
die Runde geworfen Moral Moralismus
dieser deutsche Moralismus der in meinen
Augen in diesem Jahr auch kein gutes
Jahr hatte ist aber so ähnlich wie die
wie die Nationalelf in Katar vor die
Pumpe gelaufen ist so ist ein bisschen
auch dieser deutsche Moralismus
gegenüber gelaufen ja
[Gelächter]
hatte ich hatte ein Erlebnis ich war bei
einer Zahnarzt beim Zahnarzt und da
sagte eine eine junge Zahnarzthelferin
guckt mich plötzlich so an und sagte
wissen Sie Ernst ich ich gucke ja
Fußball aber ich weiß ja gar nicht ob
ich das überhaupt noch darf und da
dachte ich ist das irre also wenn wir
das erreicht haben mit diesen ewigen
binden Debatten und diesem ewigen
erhobenen moralischen Zeigefinger ja den
wir wirklich diesen diesen Eimer Moral
den wir wie eine Monstranz vor uns her
tragen ja speziell wir als Deutsche dass
wir das erreicht haben dass eine eine
ganz normale nette Zahnarzthelferin ja
ich weiß was sie darf nicht mehr weiß ob
sie das jetzt noch darf ob sie noch mal
Fußball gucken darf so gedacht nee jetzt
reicht das ist ja wirklich wir haben
eine eine Stelle liebe Grüße an Denise
wir haben eine hohe Stufe der Diktatur
der öffentlichen Korrektheit erreicht
und für mich ist dieses Jahr 2022
aus innenpolitischer Perspektive sage
ich das jetzt erstmal also als Bilanz
der Regierungskoalition das Jahr der
gesinnungs-ethischen Überanstrengung
gewesen ja also ich glaube noch nie hat
eine Regierung so hohe moralische
Maßstäbe an sich selbst und an andere
gelegt wirklich und dabei unweigerlich
so viel Doppelmoral produziert ich
glaube das kann man in dieser
Superlative schon Form sagen ja also
selten hat die deutsche Politik versucht
so mit Werten rumzuhantieren ne und und
speziell der Umgang mit Katha weil wir
gerade über Fußball reden der zeigt das
ja wie wie unglaublich das schief geht
da passt ja nichts zusammen ne also zu
dem Zeitpunkt als man noch etwas machen
können ne vor einem Jahr als die
Regierung auch ins Amt kam hat man
nichts gemacht und dann wurde man Teil
eines entrüstungskurs eines medialen
entrüstungskurs der drei Wochen vor der
Fußballweltmeisterschaft losgehen genau
in dem sicheren Wissen dass wir ja doch
nichts verändern wird dass die
Mannschaft also teilnimmt und dass die
deutschen Firmen die an den Stadien
mitgebaut haben ja ihre Arbeit
sorgfältig erledigt haben und ihr Geld
kriegen und so weiter in diesem Wissen
um all das ja hat man auf einmal die
Moral entdeckt ja das ist natürlich für
dich daneben gewesen und auch diese
diese Aktion also ich verstehe was Frau
Feser vorhatte als sie sich mit der
Binde neben Infantino gesetzt hat aber
das sind ja Symbole die am Ende ja gar
nichts bringt ja das bringt ja am Ende
nichts mehr interessant wäre gewesen
wenn Frau Feser nachdem sie
Innenministerin geworden wäre großen
Druck auf den DFB gemacht hätte und zu
sagen pass auf wir fahren nicht nach
Katar und ihr findet doch bestimmt ein
paar mächtige Gleichgesinnte die das
auch nicht tun ja dann hätte ich großen
Respekt gehabt aber das ist doch Lehrer
Symbolismus gewesen ja es war also ich
meine wenn du das mal zusammen Lehrer
Symbolismus ist auch gut Werte geleitet
der Außenpolitik ne das ist so der
Begriff dazu und im Grunde ist doch so
jeder der nicht ist wie wir der wird
belehrt
weißt du was mich daran so nervt sag die
Deutschen haben sehr sehr lange eine
Außenpolitik gemacht in der sie darauf
wohlweislich verzichtet haben und zwar
aus folgendem Grund ja der böse Satz am
deutschen Wesen soll die Welt genesen
hatte sich im Dritten Reich auf das
perverseste korrumpiert
und danach hat man in diplomatischen
außenpolitischen Angelegenheiten
versucht den das Thema Werte so klein
wie möglich zu machen und nicht mit
Werten zu missionieren und nun ist das
ja immer so wenn irgendein Ereignis
lange her ist und jetzt kommt die die
kommen die Enkel der Kriegsgeneration
dann faded das irgendwann aus dann
verblasst diese Erinnerung daran und im
gleichen Maße sind wir jetzt schon
wieder moralweltmeister geworden die
wieder jedem erklären und belehren wir
zu regieren hat und so weiter das
scheint eine unausschrottbare deutsche
Krankheit zu sein die im Augenblick ein
eine vehements angenommen hat ja total
ja wo man sich sagt haben die kein
Korrektiv mehr ja die die die die also
wir hatten doch den schönen Begriff den
doppelwumms ich würde noch mal einen
draufsetzen in Sachen moralisch wird von
Doppelmoral sprechen wir sind
doppelboral Weltmeister meine wenn du
die das mal noch mal wenn man sich das
mal auf der Zunge zergehen lässt ja was
ist in diesem Jahr alles passiert der
türkische Außenminister wird auf offener
Bühne von unserer Außenministerin gemaßt
bis ihm der Kragen platzt unsere
Außenministerin bringt es fertig China
zu drohen für den Fall dass sie
irgendwas mit Taiwan machen z.B also wer
ist Anna-Lena Werbung dass sie diejenige
ist die jetzt den Chinesen droht ja die
Kataris werden auf offener Tribüne von
unserer Innenministerin belehrt haben
wir gerade darüber gesprochen die
Chinesen die Saudis die Iraner ja den
Afrikanern ist mir auch aufgefallen
erklären wir namibia ist da Stichwort
und andere dass sie jetzt zwar Windräder
bauen sollen für uns und Solaranlagen
Photovoltaikanlagen um uns mit grünem
Wasserstoff zu versorgen aber ihre eigen
glasvorkommen nur die sie auch ausbeuten
wollen in dem Zusammenhang sollen sie
bitte selbstverständlich in der Erde
lassen weil CO2 und so böse Sache weil
das Gas von katarve das können wir
gerade sehr gut gebrauchen aber dieses
Gas da brauchen wir nicht und deswegen
soll das auch in der Erde bleiben ich
hatte neulich eine junge Frau in der
Sendung die ich persönlich sehr mag und
die sehr engagiert ist eine ich glaube
iranisch ständig die
sehr engagiert über das sprach was dort
die Iran passiert aber die dann
irgendwann sagte auf die Frage was denn
jetzt so geschehen hat sagte ja wir
müssen da jetzt dran wir müssen jetzt
dafür sorgen dass dieses Regime stürzt
und ich dachte warte mal regime change
im Iran wir also als hätte es das
Desaster im Irak nie gegeben ist völlig
Ehre wir wollen auch keinen Tracking
sehr viele
Syrien und so das Libyen und so weiter
ja das sind alles alles Einmischungen
gewesen ja der sogenannten westlichen
Welt ja
mir dazu geführt haben dass die
Verhältnisse schlimmer sind Irak ist
übrigens nur mal beiseite gesprochen ein
massiv unterschätztes Thema total wenn
man sich den Welt armuts Bericht anguckt
kein Land der Welt hat sich die
materielle Versorgungslage so sehr
verschlechtert in den letzten zehn
Jahren im Irak das ist ein Land das
quasi ins Elend abgestürzt ist total es
ist wahr ich habe mit goldene erteilt
das ist ein guter Punkt weil du hast
völlig Recht über den Iran reden wir
gerade haben wir viel gesprochen in
diesem Jahr glücklicherweise der Irak
findet quasi gar nicht statt nee was
passiert ist wenn man mit goliata zum
Beispiel unsere tolle
Korrespondentin in Kairo
lebend und arbeitend aber die eben diese
ganze Region sehr sehr gut kennt und
gerade auch den Irak bereist hat was die
dir über den Irak erzählt das ist
absolut deprimierend und übrigens
zu sagen hat das ist country ja also es
ist da ist der ist der größte Albtraum
wahr geworden in dieser Gesellschaft
passieren kann mir fällt gerade ein was
goldene ATA in dem Zusammenhang auch
erwähnt hat und auch da wieder eine
unvorstellbare Doppelmoral die Irakis
werden ja im Grunde vom Iran behandelt
wie eine iranische Provinz die sie kann
da ein die machen dort das was sie tun
verbreiten Angst und Schrecken normale
Irak über eine schiitische Mehrheit
verfügt so was die Sache für dem Iran
massiv erleichtert exakt ja das zweite
ist aber was kein Iraker mehr versteht
die verstehen auch an dem Punkt wieder
unsere Doppelmoral nicht die sagen
moment mal ihr treibt Handel mit
Saudi-Arabien ihr holt euch Erdgas aus
Katar ihr holt es von überall her ihm
macht Geschäfte mit dem Iran
selbstverständlich ihr habt bis vor
kurzem und ein Teil immer noch mit den
Russen Geschäfte gemacht die kein
Problem damit wir sitzen auf riesigen Öl
und Gasvorkommen und wir kriegen keine
Chance aber keine Chance dass in
irgendeiner Form auszubeuten bzw ein
bisschen Geld damit zu verdienen damit
dieses geschundene Land wieder auf die
Beine kommen keine wirft sich dafür die
breche das finde ich finde ich ehrlich
gesagt atemberaubend nach dem was wir
dort an Schuld auf uns geladen haben ja
wie heißt der Westen richtig jetzt würde
ich das ja natürlich gerne mal in meinem
Kopf irgendwie aufräumen und sagen diese
Werte geleitete Außenpolitik dann gibt
es zwei Interpretationsmöglichkeiten für
mich in die eine
Interpretationsmöglichkeit ist zu sagen
das ist gut gemeint ja aber das ist eben
eine gesinnungsethische Überanstrengung
die nicht funktioniert
die zweite Interpretation wäre zu sagen
dass es gar nicht ernst gemeint das ist
vielleicht nur ein Kampfbegriff also
vielleicht ist Werte geleitet der
Außenpolitik einfach nur Synonym um zu
erklären dass wir entgegen unserer
Tradition in der Ukraine Waffen in ein
Kriegsgebiet geliefert haben vielleicht
ist das nichts anderes als sozusagen ein
euphemistische Beschreibung für eine
Abkehr von einer bisherigen Politik
vielleicht ist das gar nicht in dem
umfassenden Sinne wie wir das jetzt
interpretieren überhaupt je ernst
gemeint gewesen
darauf hätte ich gerne antworten das
würde ich gerne wissen ich hätte gerne
genau Erklärung gehabt für was und in
welchem Umfang Werte geleitet der
Außenpolitik eigentlich gelten soll ja
wenn wir gerade dabei sind also
sozusagen die Nummer die zwei
offensichtlichsten Widersprüche bevor
wir mal vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen
tiefer einsteigen ich meine nicht nur
Werte geleitet sondern feministische
Außenpolitik wie lange wie viele Tage
hat es gedauert
bis Annalena baerbock etwas zur Sache
der Frauen im Iran eingefallen ist
verdammt lange außerdem bedeutet
feministische Außenpolitik wenn man es
ernst nehmen würde und wie gesagt das
wird ja nicht besonders ernst genommen
wie Du am Beispiel des Iran ja gerade
gezeigt hast wenn man es wirklich ernst
nehmen würde würde das bedeuten dass wir
unser westliches Frauenbild aus dem Jahr
2022 zum Maßstab machen für das
Frauenbild andere Kulturen und anderer
Länder genau und überhaupt nicht darüber
nachdenken dass unser Frauenbild vor 50
vor 100 Jahren oder vor 200 Jahren auch
mal völlig anders ausgesehen hat und man
sich vorstellt wie das denn wohl gewesen
wäre wenn andere Länder bei uns hätten
versucht zu missionieren um etwas bei
uns für die Emanzipation der Frau zu tun
das hätten wir aber als völlig dämliche
Einmischung in unserer Angelegenheiten
empfunden und gesagt das geht die gar
nichts an und wir dürfen uns auch nicht
wundern wenn Länder das heute genauso
machen
es gehört ja auch dazu zu unseren Werten
in viel beschworenen werten das ist eine
Souveränität von Nationalstaaten gibt
über ihre Geschicke selbst zu
entscheiden wenn wir diesen Wert aber
hoch achten können wir sie dann
moralisch belehren im Hinblick auf
Frauenrechte zum Beispiel im Hinblick
auf demokratische oder autokratische
Regierungsform bei diesen Dingen kommen
wir automatisch jedes Mal in ein
Widerspruch an ja das scheint keiner zu
merken na du siehst es ja auch es sind
dieselben Leute wird mal Frage warum
wenn wir das ernst meinen mit unseren
Werten und jetzt sollten wir vielleicht
auch gleich noch mal einen Satz darüber
reden welche Werte meinen wir denn
eigentlich ganz genau damit ja also mit
denen sich gefälligst alle anderen zu
identifizieren haben
wenn wir darüber sprechen wie können wir
dann in der Lage sein ganz entspannt
Saudi Arabien ähm
Munition kaufen zu lassen um einen Krieg
zu führen ja ein ein autokratisches
ein Gottesstaat ein autokratischer
Gottesstaat der einen vernichtenden
Krieg im Jemen führt gegen eine völlig
wehrlose Bevölkerung mit
hunderttausenden von Toten mittlerweile
und das unterstützen wir indem wir es
zulassen dass die europäische
Rüstungsindustrie Munition an die
verkauft wie kann das sein und es wäre
an der deutschen Außenministerin gewesen
das zu verhindern die hätte das
verhindern können sie hätte das
verändern können das lassen wir nicht zu
dann wäre das nicht passiert das ist von
Werte geleitete Außenpolitik von
feministische Außenpolitik ja also Saudi
Arabien das Musterland das Feminismus
dass wir hier militärisch unterstützen
aber das alles deutet doch darauf hin
dass diese Werte geleitet aus dem
Politik vielleicht gar nicht so gemeint
war wie wir das hier interpretieren
meinst du ja ich meine das okay ich
glaube Moral mal interessieren gar nicht
so fundamental gemeint ist der erste von
nun an unseren Kompass danach ausrichten
was sind im Hinblick auf unsere Werte
kompatible starten und was nicht
der Nachteil wäre nämlich es blieben
relativ wenige starken übrig vor allem
diese Staaten wo wir Rohstoffe her
beziehen von dem lieben ganz ganz wenige
am Ende übrig
und deswegen kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass das je in diesem Sinne
überhaupt ernst gemeint war aber
trotzdem überleg dir das mal Ende
September genehmigt der
Bundessicherheitsrat die Lieferung von
Munition für Eurofighter Jets nach
Saudi-Arabien das ist ihre und um in
Jemen Menschen zu und zivile Ziele zu
bombardieren und wer Bock hat diese
Entscheidung nicht aufgehalten obwohl
sie es gekonnt hätte sondern die hat
einfach durchlaufen lassen und sagt dann
hinterher
das musste man leider so machen weil
sonst würden arme Kinder in Deutschland
bleiben
in Deutschland nein das war das war eine
interessanter zusammen also lieber
sollen arme Kinder im Jemen sterben als
arme Kinder in Deutschland leiden habe
ich das richtig verstanden hast du
richtig verstanden ja und die und die
Begründung auf dem partei-tag war das
wurde sie dafür abgefallen die
Begründung war wenn Deutschland aus
diesem gemeinsamen Rüstungsprojekt mit
dem Euro weiter aussteigen würde dann
müsste es mehr Geld für Rüstung ausgeben
dass dann bei der Kindergrundsicherung
fehlt darauf musst du mal kommen
das ist perfide das kann man nicht
anders sein liebst du im Moment ständig
dass auch auch wenn es um den um den
mali-einsatz zum Beispiel geht der wird
dann damit erklärt auch wieder Annalena
bärburg der wird damit erklärt dass man
sagt wir wollen das dort Kinder zur
Schule gehen dürfen aber der
mali-einsatz wenn der ist nicht dafür da
um Schulwege zu sichern sondern der ist
dafür da islamistin ihre Schranken zu
weisen warum warum auch da wieder ne ist
ist doch wunderbar wenn der schöne
Nebeneffekt ist dass Kinder zur Schule
gehen können es ist wunderbar niemand
hat etwas dagegen aber was mit den
Kindern hat eine lange Tradition also
man hat die Grünen hat man damals
gewonnen für die Einsätze im Afghanistan
indem man ihn nicht gesagt hat was
natürlich auch eine große Rolle spielt
Geo strategische Bedeutung Afghanistans
als Land gestützt oder Flugzeugträger in
dieser in diesem Drehkreuz quasi ja
zwischen einmal Russland und Iran und
Türkei und so weiter ne dass das eine
zentrale Bedeutung nein man hat gesagt
es geht darum die Frauen zu beschützen
Mädchen zu beschützen damit sie in die
Schule gehen können so so und was das
Wert ist haben wir ja bei dem
fluchtartigen Abzug aus Afghanistan
gesehen da war es plötzlich von einem
Tag auf den anderen nicht mehr wichtig
das Mädchen in die Schule gehen können
und wir haben uns auch keine Gedanken
darüber gemacht was mit all die Mädchen
ist die die ganze Zeit in die Schule
gehen konnten und die jetzt abgestraft
dafür werden weil sie ohne Schutz ja im
Grunde genommen gar keinen Schutz mehr
in der Gesellschaft haben und man ihnen
das zulasst legt ja genau aber also da
sieht man ja wieder diese gesinnungs
ethische Überanstrengung und das sind
alte Tradition bei den Grünen ja die den
Grünen muss man nicht mit Interessen
kommen was für alle anderen Parteien
meistens ziemlich eingängig ist sondern
den Grünen muss man immer mit einer
fundamentalen Moral kommen und am besten
mit Frauen und Kindern das meine ich du
also leidende Kinder weinende Kinder die
die die Träne die aus dem Kinderauge
läuft das ist so das Mindeste was du
brauchst um dann die Dinge zu begründen
die du gerade machst und das finde ich
das finde ich ehrlich gesagt Hahne
Büchen das geht so nicht aber in diese
Sackgasse kommst Du natürlich in diese
Ecke wenn du alles immer moralisch
auflädst ne du Moral ist
ethische Abrüstung aus mehreren Gründen
also einen wichtigen Punkt haben wir ja
jetzt angesprochen das ist weil man dann
automatisch Doppelmoral produziert man
kann keine moralische Außenpolitik
machen die unangreifbar ist die
vollkommen Werte basiert ist und so
weiter dann würde Deutschland als ein
Land das mit sehr vielen Ländern in der
Welt handelt und selber aber sehr wenig
Rohstoffe verfügen
überhaupt nicht mehr wenn wir das eine
Sekunde ernst nehmen nein dann würde
kein einziges Teil mehr von irgendwoher
beziehen weil irgendwo in irgendeinem
Produkt ist immer irgendetwas drin aus
einem problematischen Land wenn ich das
für eine halbe Sekunde ernst nehmen
würden wäre heute Feierabend mit
verketten Ende so einfach ja also
deswegen zwingt das Ganze zu Doppelmoral
und das zweite ist natürlich das
philosophisch noch spannendere Thema und
das ist sozusagen worin geht unsere
moralische Lizenz andere Länder zu
moralisieren
das ist auch eine wichtige Frage ja
also es gibt ja immer wenn wir China
kritisieren dann sagen die Chinesen
immer ja das ist Einmischung in Ina
Chinesisch Angelegenheiten das ist es ja
auch aber wir sagen ja aber es ist
berechtigte Einmischung weil zum
Beispiel was wir mit den uluren da
fürchterliches machen oder die gesamte
Entwicklung Chinas mehr und mehr zu
einem Polizei und Überwachungsstaat das
wir uns da Sorgen machen Menschenrechte
und so weiter die Frage ist nur dass wir
da moralisches ungetragen haben
geschenkt ist werden wir erfolgreich
sein damit dass wir die Chinesen
belehren während wir gleichzeitig unsere
ganzen Mittelständler und unsere Firmen
ja eine Stunde nachdem die
Menschenrechte angesprochen sind all die
Verträge unterzeichnen die wir für
unsere Wirtschaft dringend brauchen
dann ist er da denken doch die Chinesen
jedes Mal warum ziehen die hier so ein
Theater ab die glauben sich doch selbst
nicht das ist doch eigentlich nicht das
Ziel solcher Belehrung Markus besteht
nicht darin irgendetwas in China zu
verändern so das Ziel dieser Belehrung
bedeutet
innenpolitisch zu punkten dass der Punkt
das ist die Botschaft nach Hause
natürlich genau
auf der anderen Seite ganz genau
die wissen das ist jetzt der Schmu für
die Kameras und innenpolitisch gut
dazustehen war mal wieder Geschäfte mit
China macht ja ich ich Jürgen Trittin
hat bei uns die schöne Geschichte
erzählt
Gerd Schröder Staatsbesuch in China
und als
die ganze Sache gelaufen ist ganz viel
Palaver über Wirtschaftsbeziehungen und
so weiter große Geschäfte Milliarden
Deals eingetütet es hat ja dann zu
seinem Pressesprecher übrigens gibt doch
an die dpa raus dass wir jetzt hier auch
über Menschenrechte und so weiter
gesprochen haben damit dass sie der
Tagesschau läuft so aber nix ist darüber
geredet worden einfach nur Bestätigung
dessen was du gerade sagst fürs
heimische Publikum es ist ja auch es ist
ja auch interessant wenn du von gerade
sagtest wir Deutsche woher kommt das
dass wir glauben die Lizenz sozusagen
für für Moralvorstellungen in der ganzen
Welt zu haben ja die die die Lizenz für
diese moralische lufthoheiten
ach so Millionen hochmoralische Menschen
genau aber weißt du weil du gerade sagst
das kommt natürlich aus unserer
Geschichte auch da wieder Anna-Lena
bärbock denk mal an die Ukraine
Annalena baerbock hat vor dem Krieg
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
abgelehnt mit welcher Begründung wegen
unserer historischen Verantwortung das
ist die größte moralische Keule die du
in Deutschland schwingen kannst und dann
wurde die gleiche Formulierung benutzt
für Waffenlieferung der pass auf dass
der Weg der historischen Verantwortung
der Wehrmacht in der Ukraine jetzt
warten müssen ja und zwar deswegen weil
sie dann auch da auf den Parteitag hat
sie dann ja einen 180 Grad Schwenk
hingelegt na dann erklärt sie hätte den
Warschau eine Überlebende aus dem
Warschauer Ghetto getroffen und diese
Frau habe ihr gesagt sie haben sich
damals mit einer Waffe verteidigt und
jetzt sei es eben an bärbox sozusagen
Verantwortung zu übernehmen auch in
Bezug auf die Lieferung von Waffen das
heißt erst muss die Vergangenheit als
Argumente gegen genau und das Argument
für erhalten und wenn du das so hörst
dann weißt Du okay an dem Punkt stimmt
mit der Argumentationskette irgendwas
nicht da funktioniert einfach die
Glaubwürdigkeit nicht die Problem
Glaubwürdigkeit stimmt in beide
Richtungen nicht genau also ich glaube
nicht dass die Grünen allein Wegner
historischen Verantwortung dagegen waren
und ich glaube auch nicht dass ihr
aufgrund der historischen Verantwortung
heute für Wasser
ich finde Anton Hofreiter als gut
erklärt der sagte immer es hat was mit
Menschenrechten zu tun und das ist für
mich eine eine konsistente Begründung an
dem Punkt ich wollte nur noch auf was
anderes hinaus warum richard ist es
deiner Meinung nach so dass dieser der
dieser wirklich dieser deutsche
Moralismus wie in viele auch
mittlerweile nennen Moralismus ist kein
positives Wort dass der so um sich
greift
ein schönes Thema ja sag mal ich glaube
also weil das mache weil Du immer recht
hast wenn du in der moralischen Ecke auf
dem Thron sitzt und sagst ja Freunde es
ist doch aber so und so Moral Moral ist
ja unteilbar Moral ist nicht
verhandelbar wenn du die Moralkeule
schwingst dann musst du aber nichts mehr
diskutieren dann ist alles klar hallo
das ist mor das siehst du ja wohl ein
also unter anderem die Folge
antiautoritärer Erziehung ist
also ja also kinder werden heute im
Vergleich zu der Art und Weise wie
Kinder vor 50 Jahren und bieten in
Jahrhunderten davor erzogen worden
natürlich viel antiautoritärer erzogen
und sehr früh nach ihrer Meinung gefragt
ne also schon mit drei Jahren müssen die
entscheiden ob die lieber erdbeerbrei
oder Bananenbrei haben wollen und so
weiter das führt dann dazu dass sie
damit 17 in der Bäckerei vor dir stehen
und sagen ich hätte gerne dass du so und
so Brötchen ist da ist da ach da ist
Schinken drin ich hätte gerne
irgendeinen haben sie solche suchen ne
dass man nachher keine Entscheidung mehr
treffen kann weil man immer gewohnt es
sich alles mögliche auszusuchen so es
bedeutet aber auch was ja eigentlich
schön ist und dass Kinder zu einem sehr
frühen Zeitpunkt mit ihren Meinungen
ernst genommen werden das ist ja neu in
der Geschichte der Menschheit ja weil
früher war das nicht so ne also was was
Kinder irgendwie Welt anschaulich
moralisch und so weiter dachten mal
völlig egal entscheiden war was sie
Erwachsenen dachten und die Kinder
sollten gefälligst das Gleiche denken
heute ist es so Kinder werden viel
schneller mündig und werden viel eher
ernst genommen das ist erstmal eine gute
Sache das führt aber auch dazu dass sie
sich zu einem sehr frühen Alter bereits
für moralisch kompetent halten
und zwar auf Maßgabe einer gefühlten
Moral jetzt würde ich diesen Satz gerne
noch mal wiederholen jetzt kommen wir
von echt interessanten Punkt
Moral ich finde das aber so also das
moralische Gefühl das entscheidet
darüber was gut und falsch ist und nicht
extreme Sachkenntnis lange Beschäftigung
mit einer Angelegenheit vom Ende her das
Ganze zu denken und so weiter diese
Dinge spielen keine große Rolle und wenn
man darin frühzeitig bestärkt wird ja
dass mein moralisches Gefühl ausreicht
um meine Position zu achten dann haben
wir am Ende ein Land das aus lauter
Menschen besteht das ständig moralisch
entscheidet und sich darin auch nicht
mehr kritisieren lässt
und auch nicht glaubt eine gewisse
Expertise zu haben um moralisch mit
holzhackerischer Sicherheit Urteile zu
fällen
und wenn das Deine Wähler sind dann
darfst du dich nicht wundern dass du das
auf ähnliche Art und Weise in der
Politik dann auch wiederfindest das
heißt also der deutsche Moralismus ist
auch die Folge eines moralismuses in der
Gesellschaft ganz sicher
viel mehr mit Moral agiert als die Leute
auf der Straße das tun oder zu Hause ich
denke über diesen Punkt müsste man
zumindest nachdenken das ist keine total
Erklärung gibt da vielleicht auch ein
paar spezielle deutsche Traditionen aber
es spielt eine große Rolle das
moralische Gefühl reicht aus um Recht zu
haben diese moralische Überlegenheit ne
die die aber und das hat dieses Jahr ja
gezeigt wenn du allein nur wenn du an
Katha denkst also ich meine Flüssiggas
aus Katha ja sehr gerne aus den USA auch
sehr gerne Fracking in Deutschland auf
gar keinen Fall vom autoritären
Präsident in Kasachstan ja doch nehmen
wir von den
Kettensägen Experten aus Saudi-Arabien
ja auch den liefern wir notfalls auch
den Munition für ihre Eurofighter und so
weiter und wie moralisch ist es
eigentlich in dem Zusammenhang
rohstoffverträge abzuschließen über
Jahrzehnte hinweg wo wir uns doch
gegenseitig in die Hand versprochen
haben das mit dem Gas und mit dem mit
den fossilen Brennstoffen das lassen wir
jetzt mal bleiben da gehen wir jetzt mal
raus sagen nein das ist aber okay das
heißt die Moral kollidiert ja ständig
mit den Interessen die einander das ist
so früher sogar mit den eigenen Politik
hat eigentlich in erster Linie handelt
aus dem Politik von Interesse es geht um
Interessen und es geht um die moralische
brähmung von Interessen also Helmut
Schmidt lebt ja nicht mehr ne aber wenn
man den gefragt hätte geht es in der
Politik um Moral oder um Interessen dann
hätte er sauber belehrt darüber ja dass
es nicht um Moral geht also ich denke
Schmidt war der Überzeugung dass Moral
in der Außenpolitik so viel verloren hat
wie Doping im Sport sondern das ist
darum geht wohl verstandene Interessen
abzusichern und durchzusetzen und das
ist eigentlich auch das was hinter den
Kulissen die ganze Zeit passiert genau
ich glaube einfach nicht dass es
ernsthaft um Moral geht ich glaube das
ist Politiker gibt die in dem Moment wo
sie moralisch reden sich selbst glauben
und sich selbst in Rührung reden können
ich glaube aber das ist im Hintergrund
und Politiker entscheiden sowas ja auch
nicht alleine sie auch Staatssekretäre
die den ganzen Arbeit machen und und und
gleich Linie und so weiter ja das ist da
überhaupt nicht humoral geht aber dann
werden ein bisschen mit moralf Albert
das meine ich also dann kannst du aber
doch nicht ständig diese Moral zu uns
Schaufenster stellen und da haben
wir die Wohnung wir sind die guten wie
gehören zu den Guten und jetzt schaut
euch mal genau an wie wir das machen
ja
auch die die wir für die bösen halten
sich selbst für die guten und uns für
die bösen das muss man überhaupt erst
einmal wissen bevor man anfängt auf
seinem moralisches Gefühl zu hören doch
das ist total richtig vertrete hier kein
bedingungslosen Relativismus ne also ich
bin ein ein großer Freund unserer
demokratischen Werte ja und ich würde
auch nicht sagen dass ich jedes Land
moralisch gleich einschätzen würde ich
würde in der riesige Unterschiede machen
ja ich bin froh in Deutschland zu leben
und ich in Katar und nicht in Russland
und ich in Saudi Arabien und ich könnte
jetzt wahrscheinlich 90% der Welt
aufzählen und ich könnte das neben dem
Wohlstand auch mit den Werten mit der
Demokratie mit demokratischen
Institutionen und so weiter begründen ja
es ist aber etwas anderes diese
Überzeugung zu haben oder mit dieser
Überzeugung zu missionieren dass der
Punkt das würde ich sauber unterscheiden
ja ich habe dieser Tage ein sehr
interessanten kommentar von stefan
Cornelius in der in der Süddeutschen zu
dem Thema gelesen der genau also
beschreibt wie genau dieses Kriegsjahr
ja im Grunde das einums andere Mal diese
Konflikte diese Kollisionen an den Tag
gefördert hat ja also einerseits die
Binde und die moralischen Belehrungen
für Katar und auf der anderen Seite dann
dieses mittlerweile ikonographische Foto
von Robert habe ja der sich vor dem
Minister da quasi verbeugt zumindest
sieht so aus auf diesem Foto und wir
sagen bitte bitte bitte also euer lG hat
mir doch sehr sehr gerne was ich so irre
finde ist und das schreibt ihm auch
Cornelius keine andere politische
Entscheidungen der vergangenen
Jahrzehnte
hat so gravierende Konsequenzen ich
glaube das haben wir alle noch gar nicht
so richtig begriffen wie die Abkoppelung
von russischen Rohstoffen weil diese
diese billige russische Energie war ja
sozusagen 50 Prozent des deutschen
Erfolgsmodells die anderen 50% sind
Exporte in problematische Länder wie
China absolut genauso
ja auf den beiden Füßen also das eine
ist die Nase was unten rausgekommen
deutsche Geschäftsmodell deutsche
wohlstandsmodell so und jetzt 50% sind
schon mal weg und jetzt fangen wir an
mit den anderen 50% zu zu zündeln zu
Dielen und sagen dem was man auf Freunde
aber das muss alles sauber zugehen alles
ganz genau im Blick haben und du siehst
ja dass er in einer Zeit wo der Westen
ohnehin droht mittelfristig so ja
langfristig ohnehin den Wirtschaft
Wettkampf mit China zu richtig
und in dem Moment mit sich mit der Moral
so im Wege zu stehen dass man sich noch
weiter ins eigene Knie schießt ja das
scheint mir nicht wirklich langfristig
strategisch durch genau das war der
Gedanke von von Cornelius der eben sagt
das ist die gravierendste Entscheidung
der letzten Jahrzehnte aber anstatt die
Konsequenzen die das hat schonungslos zu
beschreiben was das im Endeffekt auch
für den deutschen Wohlstand bedeutet ja
und jeder den ich dieser Tage spreche
kannst du neben dem Menschen sagen dir
was auf das mit dem deutschen
wohlstandsmodell das ist vorbei es kommt
jetzt einfach andere Zeit und die Leute
haben sie auch längst begriffen nur die
Politik tut noch immer so da noch was
und dort noch nicht nur weil das Haus
brennt nun auch noch die Benzinfässer da
reintippen ja
machen also wie ist es ja ohnehin so
dass es die Verschiebung der Platten
Tektonik ja die jetzt einsetzt die ja
worüber man auch noch mal neu reden kann
weil das natürlich auch was von
ausgleichender Gerechtigkeit hat ja also
über die letzten zweieinhalb
Jahrhunderte hat der Westen die Welt
beherrscht hatte von sich von überall
her Rohstoffe geholt mit äußerster
Gewalt mit Kolonien mit Unterdrückung
und so weiter und hat dann mit seinen
überlegenden Produkten die Weltmärkte
überflutet und jetzt kommt die Zeit wo
immer mehr und immer mehr sich an den
Tisch setzen und das gleiche Spiel
selber spielen das geht natürlich
insbesondere für China aber das gilt
natürlich auch für Vietnam und dahinter
gibt es auch all die schlafenden Riesen
die Indien und und und wieder Iran wenn
er den tatsächlich mal von von
Indonesien ja also da ändert sich
natürlich ganz viel ob das automatisch
bedeutet dass wir weniger haben werden
als jetzt das glaube ich ist nicht im
vollen Umfang ausgemacht aber wir müssen
uns auf eine ökonomische Weltsituation
vorbereiten indem eben viel mehr am
Tisch mit sitzen und zwar in der
gleichen Rolle in der gleichen Position
und vielleicht müssen wir sogar
irgendwann erkennen als die Größe und
die Stärke
das wird für uns für uns ohnehin ein
großes Umdenken bedeuten das heißt die
westlichen Demokratien mit ihren Werten
die jetzt wertegeleitete Außenpolitik
machen geraten durch die Verschiebung
der Plattentektonik immer mehr in die
Defensive statt in der Offensive zu sein
es gibt mehr Menschen die in
autokratisch regierten Ländern leben als
in liberalen westlichen Demokratie und
es wird in Zukunft möglicherweise noch
sehr viel mehr Menschen geben und die
werden ihn zum Teil wirtschaftlich
erfolgreichen Ländern leben mir kommt
diese Werte geleitete Außenpolitik auch
immer so ein bisschen vor was erst wenn
man in die Defensive Gerät fängt man an
so moralisch zu werden ich will jetzt
nicht sagen ideologisch aber du weißt
was ich meine ja das ich meine ich habe
gerade überlegt als du gerade sagst es
ist China als Indonesien als Stichwort
fehlen ich meine das sind gigantische
Länder gerade Indien haben wir alle
überhaupt nicht auf dem Zettel wenn wir
sagen Werte geleitet der Außenpolitik
welche Werte meinen wir denn dann also
mit Blick auf Indonesien zum Beispiel
ist das größte muslimische Land auf
Erden sind das christliche Werte über
die wir reden ich würde sagen nein das
wird in der Krise kein beeindrucken
bitte
christlich können wir nicht die Werte
der aufkündigt unsere Religion zum
Maßstab machen als eine Religion unter
vielen Religionen in der ich würde mal
sagen kommt drauf an wenn du fragst
Richard dass das meine ich ja ja wir
können doch nicht nein bei mir das
christliche Gebot der Nächstenliebe
haben was wir sehr selten praktizieren
muss das jetzt als Exportschlager in
Indonesien auf die genau gleiche Art und
Weise oder in China eingeführt werden
also Länder die ja ihre eigenen bedeuten
ja religiösen Traditionen haben also
deswegen würde ich mal Religion ganz
raus also wird mit dem Christentum zu
missionieren damit haben wir so
schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht von den
Kreuzzügen bis zum geht nicht mehr das
sollten wir völlig außen vor lassen das
dafür uns Ihnen politisch gerne eine
Bedeutung haben aber nicht
außenpolitisch
weil dann müssten wir auch zulassen dass
der Islam ein legitimes motiviert mit
ihrer seiner Religion zu missionieren
ganz genau deswegen meine ich wenn du es
auf diesem moralischen Hochsitz erstmal
sitzt der dann dann dann dann wird alles
schwierig dann verhedderst du dich von
morgens bis abends nur noch in
Widersprüche und das ist auch der
Gedanke dabei ne wenn du mal überlegst
noch mal Bär Bock und weil du vorhin
auch diese jüngeren Generationen
angesprochen hast ist dies 40 und ist in
diesem bedeutenden Amt ist
Außenministerin und vertritt die steht
schon für eine andere Politiker
Generation und auch eine andere Art
Politik zu machen und was mir da immer
wieder auffällt ist eben genau das also
die Entscheidung das so zu machen sich
davon abzukoppeln von von der billigen
russischen Energie er hat es ist so eine
weitreichende Entscheidung wie die
Entscheidung der Chinesen sich dem
Kapitalismus zu öffnen so ja und was du
doch machen musst ist doch im Grunde den
Menschen diesem Land auch und das hat ja
ganz handfest Auswirkungen auf jeden die
Konsequenzen dessen was das bedeutet
wirklich schonungslos zu beschreiben
stattdessen kommst du immer immer wieder
mit der Moral dann sagst du in der
Ukraine die Kälte und das Leid der
Kinder und die sozusagen was da als
Kriegswaffe eingesetzt wird das ist
alles nicht verboten das ist auch alles
richtig und gut aber die das und das ist
der Satz den Cornelius geschrieben hat
die größte Herausforderung der Gegenwart
auf ein moralisches Problem zu
reduzieren das ist nicht in Ordnung und
das wird der Sache auch nicht gerecht
richtig also es ist absolut meiner
Meinung also natürlich ist es wichtig
dass man für sich selbst ein moralischen
Kompass hat ja also ich plädiere nicht
für bedingungslosen machiavilismus wobei
damit ja Willi auch noch ein bisschen
Unrecht getan hat weil er hatte auch
wert und Überzeugung
der war nur der Überzeugung dass man für
seine Werte und seine Überzeugungen um
die durchzusetzen flexible Grundsätze
haben muss das heißt nicht flexible
Grundsätze im Herzen da hat man klare
Grundsätze er hat sich ja einen nicht
nur in Fürsten gewünscht sondern
eigentlich wollte die römische Republik
wieder haben aber in den Mitteln die man
nutzt ja muss man über ein Höchstmaß an
flexible Möglichkeiten und allen
diplomatischen Finessen verfügen
und ich denke das ist realistische
Außenpolitik und ich glaube dass diese
diese diese wertepolitik ich hoffe ja
dass sie nicht ernst gemeint ist habe
ich ja vorhin gesagt ich halte sie ja
für Frau bremenung aber wenn sie
irgendwo ernst gemeint wäre dann wäre es
nur eine Frage der Zeit bis auch unsere
Außenministerin lernt das ist auch nicht
funktioniert ist Richard das
interessante These von von Christian
Schüler kennst du Christiane ist auch
Philosoph Soziologe München geboren der
sagt dieser Moralismus ist letztlich
unmoralisch denn er arbeitet mit Scham
und mit Beschämung ja das ist der
Unterschied zwischen Moral und
Moralismus ja also es ist gut ethische
Überzeugung zu haben ja aber ich
unterscheiden mal Ethik und Moral also
Ethik ist die Haltung die ich habe ja
und Moral ist die das konkrete
hineingießen diese Haltung in Sitten und
Normen
und Moralismus ist diese Sitten und
Normen zum Maßstab für alles zu machen
so und da müssen wir ganz klar sagen
ethische Haltung sind was großartiges
ohne Moral kann gesellschaftlich
auskommen aber sie darf nicht doktrinär
werden und Moralismus ist immer und zu
jedem Zeitpunkt falsch
Cornelius deswegen ist das so ein gutes
Stück weißt auch in dem Zusammenhang
noch mal auf tucholski hin ist total
interessant der ja ein sehr
friedliebender Mensch war und der
angesichts des aufkommenden
Nationalsozialismus vor moralischer
Überheblichkeit warnte und sagte nichts
als Pazifist zu sein das ist ungefähr so
wie wenn ein Hautarzt sagt ich bin gegen
Pickel das hilft gegen gar nichts
das stimmt auch ich habe dieser Tage mit
Wolfgang Schäuble gesprochen das war
sehr interessant der hat in seinem in
seinem letzten Buch glaube
Grenzerfahrungen heißt es sehr
lesenswert weil vieles was er da
beschreibt das ist ein Jahr vor dem
Krieg entstanden er liest sich wirklich
wie eine düstere Prophezeiung und der
sagt wie viel von unserer Moral sind wir
bereit zu opfern für unsere Sicherheit
also wir sagen immer nur auf der
moralisch sicheren Seite zu sein und zu
sagen also wir sind auf jeden Fall gegen
Waffenlieferungen wir sind gegen
Rüstungsindustrie wir bauen
selbstverständlich keine Panzer das ist
eine Frage die wir verhandeln müssen wie
viel ist unsere Sicherheit uns das am
Ende Wert genau das ist die eine Frage
und die zweite Frage ist wie viel
Moralismus wollen wir uns leisten auf
Kosten von Wohlstand sein buchen zum
Beispiel genau spannende Frage weil man
nämlich sehr schnell davon ausgehen
gehen wenn die Wohlstands Einbußen sehr
groß werden
dann werden nicht die friedlichsten
nettesten und ausgewogensten Parteien
die stärksten in diesem Land werden ja
und wenn ich diese ganzen Konsequenzen
mir dann auch noch vor Augen führen was
dann innenpolitisch alles los ist wenn
der Wohlstand schwindet unter anderem
aufgrund eines aus meiner Sicht falsch
verstanden Moralismus
das muss man ja auch alles mit in die
moralische Waagschale werfen
ja also wenn man einmal mit Moral
anfängt dann hat man ja nicht nur
Handlungen sondern man auch Folgen von
Handlungen Ergebnisse und wiederfolgen
von folgen und Folgen von Folgen von
folgen da gibt es dieses schöne schöne
philosophische Wort der Kontingenz
diversifizierten Nebenfolge Konflikte ja
das ist der ganze Scheiß den man sich
einhandelt weil man etwas will und den
man nicht voraus berechnen kann genau
und die moralischer man agiert umso mehr
Kontingenz diversifizierbare Nebenfolge
Konflikte kommen dabei raus
sag noch mal Kontingenz
diversifizierbare Nebenfolge Konflikte
spannend das das ich sag's mal anders in
der in der Regel besteht eigentlich die
Wahl in der Realpolitik zwischen zwei
übelne
wenn du das so beschreibst
also das ist ein gut und ein Böse gibt
das ist ja das was mich daran so
störtlich nur zweistellige Ethik es gibt
nur schwarz und weiß ja genau ja und
darauf haben wir ja schon mal in
politisch ganz viel geredet dass die
Grautöne aus der Gesellschaft und aus
den Debatten verschwinden und ich meine
das ist das Gegenteil von diplomatie ist
schwarz und weiß genau diplomatie ist
die Kunst auf der Klaviatur der Grautöne
zu spielen ja und das darf kein Staat um
seiner Existenz und seines
wirtschaftlichen Erfolgs deswegen
aufgeben aber ich finde diesen Gedanken
so gut also es ist noch nicht mal
Realpolitik das siehst Du am Beispiel
Katha Robert habe der sich da quält und
mit seinem Staatsbesuchen und andere
oder die Frage Scholz in China und so ja
es ist noch nicht mal die Wahl zwischen
Schwarz und Weiß die Wahl zwischen dem
einen guten und dem anderen besseren ne
sondern
darin bewegt sich aus Russland und Gas
aus Katar das ist hier genau die Wahl
zwischen schwarz und schwarz und das ist
interessant weil weil das dann bedeutet
dann sollten wir doch mal aufhören das
ständig als Moral zu verkaufen sondern
sollten wir doch einfach sagen pass auf
Freunde Moral ist hier nicht wir finden
es theoretisch alles gut und schön und
wo es geht machen wir es auch aber in
Wahrheit reden wir hier von Interessen
und dann hast du dieses ganze Thema
nicht mehr dann sagst du okay dann nehme
ich das kleinere Übel und ich das
größere Übel aber das dient jetzt mal im
Interesse ja schlicht und ergreifen so
ist das moralische Abrüstung wir sind
uns einig ja ja also ideale und Moral ja
sind das beste Mittel um das große Loch
zu füllen was man Glaubwürdigkeit nennt
ja das heißt also wenn man das Gefühl
hat dass man keine klare Haltung oder
Linie hat dann versteckt man sich hinter
moralischen Werten und Prinzipien und je
weniger man an seine eigenen Werte
glaubt ja umso stärker missioniert man
im Regelfall damit
ganz ganz viel dran weil jemand der
Sache ganz ganz sicher ist
muss auch nicht missionieren du machst
die eifrigsten Prediger im US-Fernsehen
haben meistens die Tiefsee meistens
ziemlich ziemlich sicher wer schon wer
schon anfängt mit Schaum vor dem Mund zu
predigen bei dem weiß man schon da
steckt irgendein tiefes Problem hinter
wahrscheinlich ist das so und da wir die
nochmal abschließen weil mich dieser
Gedanke nicht loslässt Richard du hast
das vorhin so nebenbei erwähnt ist das
eine generationfrage ja also die die
Generation heute ist mit Sicherheit sehr
viel moralischer als frühere Generation
mir fällt das
nicht einfach nur ich würde das nicht
einfach nur verdammen ja wir haben ja
schon über über die letzte Generation
gesprochen haben eines festgelegt also
wer nicht moralisch ist wenn er jung ist
ja wer diesen wer diesen diesen Feuer
dieses Feuer nicht in sich spürt die
Welt zu einem besseren Ort zu machen
der ist eigentlich für die Gesellschaft
verloren und deswegen finde ich das auch
gut und richtig und die ganze Kunst des
Lebens besteht darin diesen Funken
weiter in sich zu bewahren aber all die
Fehler die man macht wenn man den
brachial ja zu einer großen Flamme macht
die muss man eben vermeiden das heißt
also die Kunst des Lebens besteht darin
dass irgendwann die Klugheit so Moral
kommt und das bedeutet nicht die Moral
aufzugeben aber es bedeutet die Moral
nicht mehr vor sich her zu tragen
ja das ist richtig und wird gerne noch
was hinzufügen was du ja häufig siehst
und erlebe ich auch häufig bei den
Leuten die ich so treffe die haben mir
alle immer so angefangen so als Junge
Moralisten ja die wirklich das Gute in
der Welt wollten und sie enden dann aber
so häufig als zynische alte Säcke das
stimmt und das ist dann ist mir der
Junge Moralist lieber als der zyllische
alte Sack ich glaube auch also
das geht mir ganz genauso also der
zynische alte Sack ja in den lavros
dieser Welt
mit Sicherheit nicht genießen ja also
diesen deswegen sage ich ja den
moralischen Funken muss man sich beraten
ja und ein ethischen Kompass im Leben
braucht man auch ja aber die Klugheit ja
ja die hilft einem ja auch zu lernen
weil man den richtigen Gebrauch von
Moral macht wie man moralsituation am
wichtigsten einsetzt wann sie besonders
angebracht ist und man vielleicht
weniger und diese Klugheit muss zur
Moral kommen das moralische Gefühl
alleine reicht für ein Leben nicht hin
genau und ich würde gerne noch
hinzufügen ich sag mal so zur zum Moral
ist gerade in diesem vergangenen Jahr
aus deutscher Sicht häufig auch so ein
eine gefühlte ich glaube viele um uns
herum haben das so wahrgenommen so eine
gefühlte Arroganz gekommen diese
moralische Überheblichkeit und ich
glaube wir wir hätten gut daran da mal
ein bisschen abzurüst und uns fürs
nächste Jahr einfach mal eine Runde Demo
zu verordnen das finde ich klingt gut
ich finde unser Vorsatz fürs nächste
Jahr sollte sein dass wir zwei keine
Säcke werden und uns hoffen ja dass
sowohl wir wie die Welt um uns herum ein
klein bisschen demütiger wird wir
inklusive wir inklusiv ja ich danke sehr
ich danke dir auch spannend
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]